on board the wallow a sagales warship
preparing for a special
mission Captain Le is checking the radar
a fishing vessel filled with hundreds of
African migrants is heading to Europe it
was spotted by a plane from the Spanish
Guardia civil the crew mission is to
intercept it before it reaches European
Waters it's a kind of war and we have to
save them because we know all the
dangers they are facing waves all the
the winds that's why we are putting a
lot of means in order to block them to
save them they venture out of the harbor
and into the open ocean in search of a
boat that looks like this a tiny fishing
vessel made of wood somewhere out there
in the Atlantic traffickers pack
hundreds of migrants into small boats
like this they use a simple GPS to
navigate the 1,500 km that separates
Sagal to the the Spanish
archipelago we're sailing hundreds of
nautical miles away from the coast and
the immensity of the task at hand
becomes visible a few sagales Navy ships
with a tasks to stop an
unprecedented wave of migration to
Europe braving treacherous conditions a
record
32,000 African migrants have made it to
the Canary Islands this year alone but
no one knows how many have been lost at
sea drowned or
capsized we cross mortanian Waters
captain Lee is worried night falls 19
hours into the search still no sign of
the
boat we have failed these are lives that
we have not managed to save given the
weather conditions between marania and
the Canary Islands it's unlikely they
will make it with weather conditions
worsening captain Lee and his crew
decide to return towards sagal's Coast
but the Wall's Mission isn't over just
yet the crew scans the ocean in the hope
of finding somewhere in the darkness a
sign of Life Nicholas Hawk Al jazer off
the coast of
morania make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer